[Music]
on this Monday night
coronavirus confirmed in Canada one
official case another presumptive case
their connection this new case isn't
surprising plus new questions over how
the virus spreads scouring for clues in
the Kobe Bryant helicopter crash it's a
logistical nightmare the choppers final
moments in the air the liberation of
Auschwitz 75 years later the
immeasurable pain for survivors everyone
turning their back on us and the mission
to educate the next generation
we cannot allow history to repeat itself
and honorable mention one man's lifelong
dream fulfilled by the Mounties
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is now official Canada has its first
confirmed case of the new strain of
corona virus a man in his mid 50s in
Toronto his wife is also suspected of
being ill and is awaiting test results
they are both in isolation and both
recently traveled from Wuhan China the
epicenter of this coronavirus outbreak
I'd like to stress that since arriving
in Toronto this individual has been in
South isolation as such the risk to
Ontarians remains low Canadian health
authorities say the greatest concern is
people who have symptoms of the illness
and have traveled to Wuhan or the
surrounding who Bay province where the
greatest quarantine in history is
underway that is the epicenter and it's
where the vast majority to have
contracted the virus live the latest
numbers from China there are more than
40 100 confirmed cases now in that
country and 106 deaths most of them in
and around Wuhan there are concerns the
number of people carrying the virus but
not yet showing symptoms could be far
higher researchers at Hong Kong
University estimate 43,000 people in
Wuhan could be carrying it China's
premier met frontline workers in Wuhan
today and promised to send 2,500 more
medical workers to help and this is day
4 of the rush construction of a special
hospital in Wuhan just to house up to
1000 patients with the virus there are
reports it can be spread by people who
are not showing any symptoms which
raises questions about the ability to
contain it that's one of many remaining
unknowns about this virus as Heather
Eurex West reports Canadian health
officials say two Canadians have become
ill with the new corona virus linked to
a deadly outbreak in China the two cases
are as you know a married couple who
arrived at Pearson International Airport
on January 22nd a man in his 50s the
country's first confirmed case remains
at Sunnybrook Hospital in Toronto his
wife now considered a presumed case has
a milder form of the illness and is in
isolation at home as of today she has
not been in need of the same acute
hospital care required by her husband
who also remains stable the public
health agency of Canada
expects to see more cases in the coming
days 19 other patients are being tested
for the new strain in Ontario alone but
officials say the risk of an outbreak in
Canada remains low that is the primary
message that I want to give Canadians
the risk of contracting coronavirus is
low and I think there are risks of
contracting other viruses that are here
in Canada that we know a lot about that
is that are much higher more public
health resources are being deployed to
the Toronto Montreal and Vancouver
airports to help screen passengers
arriving from China anyone returning
from Wuhan is being asked if they are
ill Chinese health officials revealed
over the weekend that this virus could
spread before patients become
symptomatic Canada's chief public health
officer says she see no evidence to
support that claim
we certainly need more data to really
evaluate the veracity of that claim
because certainly it would be extremely
unusual for something like that to
happen but the uncertainty surrounding
the spread of the new strain of the
virus is prompting concern I mean it's
much good to put protect myself and my
family in Winnipeg medical masks have
become difficult to find
even though health officials believe
those kinds of precautions aren't
necessary right now Canada's health
minister says she's asked her department
to set up a federal 1-800 number to
answer questions and clear up confusion
about the illness as the global medical
community learns more about the new
strain and its spread with each passing
day Heather your exbest Global News
Calgary fans of former NBA legend Kobe
Bryant are still reeling today Bryant
was on his private helicopter with his
13 year old daughter and seven others
including kids parents and a coach they
were going to his youth basketball
academy in California when the
helicopter crashed it was foggy when it
happened and today investigators from
the National Transportation Safety Board
asked the public to send photos of the
skies at the time they said the
helicopter was climbing to avoid a cloud
layer it was not required to carry a
black box and it did not have one the
accident scene they said is quite
devastating and it will take time to
recover the bodies this was a
heartbreaking scene at Bryant's
basketball academy when they heard the
news the children took a knee when they
realized Bryant
wouldn't be coaching anymore and his
daughter wouldn't be playing in Los
Angeles where Brian played his entire
20-year career memorials with flowers
and candles are growing outside the
Staples Center and in New York City
tonight the Empire State Building is lit
up in purple and yellow the colors of
the LA Lakers
as a tribute to the superstar today the
Basketball Hall of Fame joined the rest
of the world mourning the loss
announcing Bryant will be the first
inductee of the 20/20 class here's Mike
drily
on the music industry's biggest night
the tributes poured in for Kobe Bryant
and we're literally standing here
heartbroken a basketball star whose
appeal went beyond his sport at
makeshift memorials and on the air tears
came easily
I just don't have a lot to say yeah
the news is just devastating to
everybody as sports fans mourn the loss
of the 41 year old investigators combed
through the wreckage for clues as to how
one of the safest helicopters in the air
crashed into the side of a mountain in
California it's a logistical nightmare
in a sense because a crash site itself
is not easily accessible what they
already know is that the fog was so
thick the Los Angeles Police Department
had grounded its choppers and that the
pilot of Bryant's chopper had been given
special clearance to fly in bad
conditions I heard a look up there
flying like I felt like it was flying
way too low and all of a sudden I hear
like a thud noise and then there was
nothing rescue personnel reported all
nine people on board had died including
Brian's 13 year old daughter Gianna also
on board a college baseball coach John
Altobelli
his wife Carrie and their daughter
Alyssa 13 year old Payton Chester and
her mom Sarah and girls basketball coach
Christina Mouser
and the pilot Bryant retired nearly four
years ago after a celebrated career to
spend more time with his wife and four
daughters but he was arguably busier
than ever who gave a sushi oh boy his
ladies room
and how always looking for it
winning an Oscar in 2018 for Best
Animated Short
I'm as basketball players we're really
supposed to shut up in dribble but I'm
glad I'm glad we do a little bit more
than that that he did which in part
explains his broad appeal and the
sadness that's overwhelmed so many of
his fans might relate Global News
Toronto new information has emerged that
could be a game changer in the
impeachment trial of President Donald
Trump and it comes from a man who used
to be very close to the president John
Bolton his former national security
adviser has written a book it's not out
yet but part of it has been leaked to
the New York Times and it undercuts a
key part of President Trump's defense
now as Jackson prosecco explains the
Democrats are hoping Bolton will become
a star witness at the impeachment trial
I haven't seen the manuscript but I can
tell you nothing was ever said - taking
up his own defense President Donald
Trump denied explosive new claims from
his former national security advisor
John Bolton contained in a looming
tell-all book according to the New York
Times Bolton writes that Trump told him
to freeze 400 million dollars in
military aid to Ukraine until officials
there helped with the investigations
Trump wanted into his rival Joe Biden
that directly contradicts the
president's ongoing impeachment defense
the pause on security assistance was
distinct and unrelated to investigations
he's highly respected by everybody in
this room once a close Trump ally Bolton
left the White House late last year
White House officials have testified he
was aware of the scheme to pressure
Ukraine and angrily called it a drug
deal I think at this stage is pretty
fair to say that John Bolton has a
relevant testimony to provide whether
Bolton is allowed to testify remains an
open question
the facts of the case remain the same
there is nothing new here the Republican
majority has so far blocked attempts to
hear from witnesses several would have
to break ranks to change that we have a
witness with first-hand evidence of the
president's actions for which he is on
trial he is ready and willing to testify
how can Senate Republicans not vote to
call that witness Jackson pre-orders are
already being taken for Bolton's book do
we know how this explosive stuff in it
was leaked well Donna an advanced copy
of the book had apparently been given to
national security officials for vetting
as is standard practice with someone in
Bolton's situation but the question many
Republicans have is whether the White
House knew about the allegations
contained within the book and if so
whether they kept this all quiet as
Republican members were out there
offering this vigorous defense of the
president's on TV Donna all right lots
more to emerge on this Jackson prosecco
in Washington thanks just days before
the third anniversary of the shooting at
a Quebec City mosque lawyers are arguing
over the prison sentence for the gunman
Alexander bissonnette's lawyer and crown
prosecutors are both appealing the
sentence last year he was given life in
prison with no possibility of parole for
40 years in January of 2017 he stormed
into a Quebec City mosque during evening
prayers killing six men and wounding
several others visa Nets lawyer argues
that sentence is too harsh and that the
crimes were not motivated by prejudice
against Muslims
prosecutors say Bissonnette should not
be eligible for parole for 50 years
considering the seriousness of the
crimes piece annette was not in court
today and a decision is not expected for
some time while there are times when
words cannot express cannot do justice
and that's the case at a ceremony in
southern poland today 75 years ago on
january 27th 1945 the Soviet Red Army
liberated the sick and starving
survivors of Auschwitz the scale and the
horror of what the Nazis did was and is
unimaginable today there were prayers
and tears and a warning that the evil
that led to the Holocaust still lurks
Redman Shannon reports the pain is as
clear today as it was 75 years ago more
than 200 survivors made the trip back to
Auschwitz all wearing blue and white
striped scarves and hats just like the
prisoner uniforms at the most deadly of
all the Nazi death camps a place where
1.1
people were murdered most of them Jews
oh yes ouch Schmitz didn't just fall
from the sky Marian torski told fellow
survivors and world leaders by that he
meant there had been a slow creep of
anti-semitism across Europe leading up
to the Holocaust when European Jews take
the world for a safe harbor somewhere to
go the entire world turned its back on
them World Congress of Jews President
Ronald Lauder says open hostility toward
Jews has returned in a way he never
could have imagined in 2020 we hear the
same lies the Nazis used so effectively
in the propaganda Jews control
everything we hear this madness online
in the media and even within democratic
governments among the government leaders
present was Hungary's Viktor Orban he is
referred to expat Jewish billionaire
George Soros as dishonest and crafty
tropes used against Jews for generations
countries across Europe have seen marked
increases in anti-semitic crimes in
recent years one Jewish Canadian living
in Germany says he no longer wears his
capaz skullcap in public it's just
doesn't feel as anywhere near as
comfortable as safe being Jewish in
Berlin as it did when I came in 2017
Aaron Solomon says since the deadly
synagogue attack in Germany last fall
he's noticed more security near Jewish
landmarks there's this old Jewish saying
that you always need to have that
suitcase packed and we always physically
have that suitcase packed here in
Germany as their numbers dwindle these
survivors fear Europe's collective
memory of the Holocaust is fading to
Redman Shannon Global News London as a
Redmond mentioned the number of
survivors is dwindling coming up how and
why the next generation is keeping their
stories alive Plus dope
decision a Canadian canoeing champ gets
some welcome news
hello helping the community nothing
matters outside of that room
the only thing that matters is that
person on the table giving back we
provide about thirty to forty thousand
meals to people in need every single
month I'm gonna bite from Vancouver to
Halifax but it's so much more than that
it's meeting with families and giving
them that help making a difference we're
just trying to provide these
breakthroughs for these kids because I
think it's in all of our DNA we're
supposed to do things for other people
every day hero on global national
another Tory MP is in the running for
the leadership Aaron O'Toole from
Ontario made it official by releasing a
video by Mary O'Toole and I'm running
tonight conservatives today O'Toole was
in Alberta he says that province is a
priority for him he's vowing to fight
for jobs and defend Canada from what he
calls the radical left mrs. O'Toole
second attempt at becoming Tory leader
he ran in 2017 when Andrew Shearer won
the party is set to pick its new leader
on June 27th an MP's were back to work
in the House of Commons today after a
lengthy winter break the first test for
the minority government of Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau is ratifying the
new NAFTA agreement the Liberals are
preparing to table legislation to ratify
the deal also known as Kuzma it could be
a bumpy road they need support from at
least one other party to pass any bill
the NDP and the bloc québécois
are stalling for now not committing to
passing the legislation quickly the
Conservatives say they want more clarity
on the impact the deal will have on
industries like forestry and agriculture
lies one of Canada's top Olympic medal
hopefuls has been cleared of doping
canoeist Lawrence Vincent Lapointe
convinced an international panel that
she did not knowingly take the banned
muscle-building drug ligand role the
tribunal ruled her positive test was
caused by third party contamination
Vincent Lapointe can now return to
training and can still qualify for the
Olympic debut of women's canoe sprint at
the Tokyo Games this summer ahead
frightening flight a passenger plane
forced to take an unexpected detour
you are watching global national this
remarkable scene happened in Iran a
passenger plane crash-landed on the
runway of a nearby airport and then
skidded on to a city highway but
remained intact and people were able to
climb out only two of the hundred and
forty-four people on board suffered
injuries the plane had traveled from
Tehran and according to Iranian media
reports the pilot was unable to deploy
the landing gear some heartbreaking
images in the Mediterranean Sea tonight
as the worsening security situation in
Libya is prompting more people to risk
their lives getting to Europe nearly 500
migrants many suffering hypothermia and
dehydration were rescued from the water
over the weekend the ocean Viking one of
two private rescue ships in the
Mediterranean ended up with double the
number of people it has capacity for
almost 40 percent of those rescued or
children under the age of 18 and the
youngest is just six months old more
trouble for one of the Queen sons Prince
Andrew a prosecutor in New York City
says the Prince has not followed through
on his pledge to help in the Jeffrey
Epstein sex trafficking case today
present Prince Andrew has provided zero
cooperation Jeffrey Berman says the FBI
contacted Prince Andrew's lawyers about
interviewing him but have not heard back
investigators are talking to individuals
connected to Epstein about an alleged
sex trafficking operation of underaged
girls in an interview last year the
prince who was a friend of Epstein's
said he was willing to help with any
law-enforcement agency and their
investigation there are calls to boycott
a new British coin created the
government says as Britain enters the
post brexit era the problem is both
about politics and punctuation the new
50 pence coin bears the slogan peace
prosperity and friendship with all
nations but people like British author
Sir Philip Pullman say the brexit coin
is missing an Oxford comma and should be
boycotted by all literate people the
Oxford comma should be used after the
word prosperity some are so incensed
about both the punctuation and the coins
claim they say they'll refuse to care
next the ongoing efforts to keep the
stories of Holocaust survivors alive
watch the award-winning newscast that
covers and uncovers the stories that
affect Canadians global national would
done a freezin they are the last living
witnesses to the horrors of the
Holocaust and at Auschwitz today on the
75th anniversary the Nazi death camp was
liberated the focus was on the survivors
this may be the last time so many gather
in one place many live in Canada as well
as their descendants are trying to keep
their stories alive
Abigail Beeman looks at what's being
done and why it's so important I
appeared naked in front of this dr.
Mengele Richard Lewis father Leo
survived Auschwitz fifteen-year-old Leo
was a twin experimented on daily by the
infamous dr. Mengele known as the angel
of death
Leo lived until 2002 it was asked to
present my dad's story called Leo's
journey now on the 75th anniversary of
the death camps liberation
Richard released a new film online where
he narrates his father's experience
Leo's journey in my father's words these
survivors came up and they started
hugging me and thanking me and
appreciating the fact that they have the
feeling that the story will continue
after they're gone it's already being
offered as a resource for teachers in
British Columbia and Richard plans to
take his father's story around the world
even though I'm old I am one of the
youngest survivors survivors who are
still able to share their stories
directly say educating the next
generation is paramount the use that we
speak to today is the last generation
who will actually meet a person who
survived especially as Canada and the
world faced an increase in anti-semitism
the desire to recognize that these signs
are around us everywhere and that we
cannot allow history to repeat itself as
long as I am able to I am committed to
do that because I think it's absolutely
vitally important that people
should understand and listen to
witnesses out of a hundred and fifty
people in his extended family pin her
scooter was one of just five to survive
the Holocaust I lost my parents and my
twin sister he was the first survivor to
take part in an interactive project by
the USC Shoah foundation answering
hundreds and hundreds of questions so
visitors can virtually speak with him
close to a real conversation the most
important things that I that that is
very close to my heart is to educate the
young people on Holocaust Remembrance
Day he's both thankful and sad there's a
complex mix of emotions we call it
liberation but Holocaust survivors were
never actually liberated because you
live with the Holocaust inside you all
the time doing all he can to make the
phrase never again a reality Abigail
Beeman Global News Ottawa and that is
global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's here Canada is a
special moment for a man from Manitoba
whose only dream in life was to be an
RCMP officer back in 1951 when he was 20
Jack Russell had been accepted into the
RCMP but had to decline because his
family needed him home in Elva Manitoba
well now with just days to live his
family wanted to make Jack's wish come
true and so did the RCMP we salute you
too jack thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
you